Je dirais à quelqu'un s'il se sent
un peu gêné ou s'il a l'impression d'
être la seule personne à avoir un problème,
à quelle fréquence je parle à des gens qui
ressentent exactement la même chose qu'eux
[Musique]
je m'appelle  ethan murray et je suis un
éducateur pervers, l'éducation du roi est quelque chose
qui serait assez nouveau en Irlande pour autant
que je sache à la minute où je suis le seul
à
organiser des ateliers comme celui-ci pour découvrir ce qu'est un problème,
c'est une question vraiment intéressante.
définition de la vieille école,
les gens auraient utilisé n'importe quelle
pratique sexuelle non normative en dehors du
scénario typique que nous imaginons lorsque nous parlons de
sexualité. Qui peut définir ce qui est
normal et la vérité est que notre perception
de la normale est vraiment influencée par notre
culture,
ma première  Il y a
presque deux ans, il y a environ quatre ans, la
demande était telle que j'ai dû
en organiser deux autres, puis un
autre collège m'a demandé si j'allais diriger l'
atelier pour eux et j'ai fait venir
des gens à partir de 18 ans.  à 65 ans et plus, même
si je suis peut-être beaucoup plus jeune
que quelqu'un, ils seraient toujours à
l'aise de m'écouter, puis
j'anime un atelier appelé fierté et plaisir,
c'est un
atelier sur les jouets sexuels incluant tous les genres et la sexualité, puis mon
plus récent s'appelle le sexe sur le  Peach,
c'est un atelier dédié à l'
exploration du jeu anal. Je reçois des personnes de
toutes identités de genre et c'est
génial, mais ce serait plus de femmes. Je
rencontrerai parfois des femmes qui
se sentent très gênées de
discuter de leur propre plaisir et qui
prennent donc le temps de réfléchir.  sur ce qu'ils
aiment
et explorer une vie intime selon leurs
conditions est une étape importante pour eux, ils disent
qu'ils veulent acheter leur premier jouet sexuel ou
qu'ils veulent explorer le pervers
et même avec cela, il y a parfois
un sentiment de culpabilité ou de honte.
Musique]
les gens viennent parfois vers moi et ils me
disent et mon partenaire a ces
défauts, j'en ai des différents et
je ne sais pas quoi faire, il y a très
souvent des moyens de trouver où monter
une scène  ou une séance de jeu
ensemble qui intègre quelque chose que vous
aimez et quelque chose qu'ils aiment,
à condition que cela ne soit en dehors des limites de personne
ou en dehors de tout ce avec quoi vous êtes à l'aise.
Il est important d'apprendre
ces choses de cette façon, vous pouvez
décider si c'est quelque chose que
vous aimez.  J'aimerais vraiment y participer et
ce niveau de risque en vaut la peine pour vous ou
non. Ce que j'espère réaliser,
c'est
normaliser un peu les phénomènes pervers. Maintenant, nous ne
voulons pas supprimer complètement le tabou,
car parfois c'est ce qui rend les choses
excitantes pour les gens.
vous savez, je ne peux pas enseigner à quelqu'un tout ce qu'il
y a à savoir sur le kink ou le bdsm en
60 minutes, ce n'est pas possible, mais j'espère pouvoir
le faire réfléchir à la façon dont nous
abordons ces choses et à ce qu'il
doit rechercher lorsqu'il
'  La recherche d'informations si
répandues ou simplement le manque d'endroits où aller
pour apprendre signifie que parfois ils se
retrouveront dans des situations assez
dangereuses et je voulais faire quelque chose à
ce sujet et essayer de donner aux gens un
petit cadre pour qu'ils puissent  Je pourrais faire
des recherches moi-même, il y a certaines
activités dans le bdsm qui sont considérées comme à
plus haut risque et nous
les appelons généralement des activités de jeu de pointe,
donc c'est tout ce qui présente un
risque important de blessure, d'
invalidité ou de récurage, dans certains cas,
même de décès. Je veux encourager les gens.
pour être aussi soucieux de leur sécurité que possible,
quelle que soit la façon dont vous pourriez en penser, que leur
pli vous mette à l'aise ou
mal à l'aise, il est important que nous
essayions de les garder aussi en sécurité que possible, vous
savez qu'ils méritent toujours
que leur bien-être soit la priorité et
avoir les outils dont ils ont besoin pour prendre soin
d'eux-mêmes
[Musique]
vous